seven years ago our next guest faced a
lot of obstacles in life
and instead of giving up she turned it
all around with hard work
passion and one idea
here is her story of success
hi my name is mary ruth giam i'm the
founder and ceo
of mary ruth organics and i founded our
company in 2013.
we have a liquid vitamin company that
helps so many families
across the world the reason i started
mary ruth organics
really came from my own personal
experience
of trying to figure out health and
wellness my
42 year old father passed away suddenly
i was just 12 years
old when i was a sophomore in college
my brother also suddenly passed away
from the same heart
condition that my father had at that
moment i knew that
i wanted to spend my life dedicated
to helping people and through that
process
i decided to take a very big risk i was
in a lot of debt at the time
and start my own business i started
making liquid vitamins in 2014 it was my
mother and i
as the owners of the company just the
two of us
we now have a team of 90 people
we have 120 products so when i look back
at those defining moments
in my young adult life it really
inspired me to
one want to learn more about health and
wellness and then to create
a business that could allow me to create
financial stability at the same time
while
helping people live a healthier and
happier life
which is now today married with organics
[Music]
please welcome business owner and author
of liquids to lunch 12 small habits that
will change your life for good
mary ruth gium
first of all i have
now become the biggest fan i am now
on your liquid vitamins because i cannot
swallow pills therefore i just don't
um they make me nauseous they hurt my
chest
how did you come up with i mean there's
so many aspects to your story i want to
talk about but
let's just start with the liquid
vitamins because that was a star product
of yours
basically i had a private practice in
new york
city on 47th and 3rd where i would see
people one-on-one
all day long and i would teach them
about liquids to lunch so you can have a
green juice
vegetable broth smoothie coffee tea
whatever you want
until about 12 noon everyone would say i
love
liquids to lunch but i can't take my
vitamins anymore the capsules are making
me so nauseous like you just shared
and so at that point i thought okay i
really need to make a liquid vitamin
that's full spectrum has a little bit of
everything that someone would need
so that it will absorb well it will be
bioavailable
and most importantly will not make them
nauseous in the morning
i am obsessed with your book i
love the 12 steps i love
the drink your uh half your body weight
in ounces of water
i love to get 15 minutes of sunshine
this is my favorite
um it has never failed me i
feel like this is free and accessible to
every single person
and instantly the sun can make anyone
feel better stress less
any tips for that mary ruth oh my
goodness so
i think that time blocking i've been
passionate about time blocking for 15
years
i think every person actually knows what
makes them happy and that we just want a
little bit of time each day to do the
things that we love
and so when you create a lot of
structure in the end you'll be able to
carve out
a little bit of freedom to do all the
things that make you happy
and i have worked with people one-on-one
for so many years
and i find that this makes everyone
happy
how do you give advice to entrepreneurs
and i want them to know that you fought
a good battle
like yours did not come overnight it did
not come easy and you had a lot of
roadblocks
you just have to take the first step
even if you can't see the whole path
um usually people have an idea that they
want to do something
um the first thing is that to recognize
that that idea is unique to you
because you have that idea it means that
you are meant to move forward
so the second thing before you actually
move forward
is to have self-awareness about what
makes you happy
before you even get into the business
model this is so
important because chronologically
what you might not see is what it looks
like five years from now 10 years from
now
15 years from now once you know what
makes you happy
this is the best best starting place
because you don't want to create a
business model that in five years
when it's successful it's out of
alignment with your family or your
personal life
and then you're kind of stuck and you're
trapped so
for me i had seven hundred thousand
dollars in debt
i knew like we spoke about before that i
wanted to make these liquid vitamins
and it's very difficult to find a
manufacturer
who usually you need something like
twenty thousand dollars to do a custom
blend run of vitamins
and you were calling manufacturers oh
that's right drew i
called all over for six months with the
help of my husband
we found one manufacturer in california
and i said
listen i know you don't know me i
promise
if you make me 90 bottles just 90
bottles of this liquid
vitamin gluten-free organic sugar-free
sugar-free was the key um i promise that
someday it will be your
biggest account and i eventually was the
biggest account but at the time i mean
90 bottles i take them to my office i
sell them
some of my clients reviewed it on amazon
but at the time
amazon is not cool then this was 2014.
and i remember crying so hard the first
weekend i saw
i sold like 280 worth of vitamins
and i saw just a small way
to move forward out of this debt it's
it's about patience
and a lot of hard work and now in 2021
we have over 90
amazing amazing marry with organics
employees
i love you so much i'm so inspired by
you
thank you for having me i love your book
these 12 steps
just click with me they're doable i love
them
please check out mary
maryruthorganics.com and to find out all
about her products
and her new book liquids till lunch
thank you mary